So we've looked at the key terms and statistics and probability like the word
the jargon you will revisit them.
But now let's look at the mathematical notation. The reason
we will begin with probability.
rather than a statistics because
this is the prerequisite.
for learning the statistics notation
So either simple example suppose you have a
pair of dice.
like two of them if you have two
dice we call them a die.
If you roll the die the same time meaning you
take one dice another dice hold the Manifest in you.
roll them a simultaneously
you will get the following outcomes.
Remember the word outcome.
when you roll the dice recall that experiment
and when the
die land of the table we call that outcome.
So here are your outcomes this is your sample space.
You can either get two twos.
Or get one what we get a single one and two or you
know, you can have one six another they
want that's just one or you have one three one five
and so on.
Okay.
So this is all of your outcome.
36 of them
the exercise requires us to do the following.
Use set notation.
You set notation to list all of the possible outcomes.
pay attention to that word in a set s
I did say that we can't avoid.
getting into other areas of mathematics, but
set theories actually quite simple.
Okay, so by the way, this will be good opportunity for you to know learn more
than just probably in statistics.
But it requires us to you. I'm gonna I'm gonna show you
the answer for this. I'm going to teach you how to do this. You said
notation to list all the possible outcomes in a set as you set
notation to list the event e
remember the slide
so the first one is s for the
all of the outcomes can get it says you set
notation to list all the possible outcomes in a set
s like the entire thing and then again, you said notation
to list the event e would it die is rolled and the outcome add
up to six.
So portion of the sample space.
And then it asks once you have these two things.
What is the probability?
That number I told you about of event e in
a sample six.
Okay.
Let's see how we can answer this question.